[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to 10 250 we also have
people in for 270 and for 370 hello if
you can see me we'd like to welcome
everyone this is a really important
occasion we're on the eve of war so
thank you for being here
this is mi t--'s second evening of
events sponsored by the mi t--'s
initiative of peace and yesterday's
event was a tremendous success with over
3,000 people attending Reverend Jesse
Jackson's speech in which he urged us to
join our community fellow members and
study War no more
this was then followed by the
inauguration of the MIT Student Center
to be the Martin Luther King jr. Peace
Center and where we will be having many
different various activities organized
for example we have discussions open
discussions workshops
there'll be newspapers political art
political theater many many different
things and we urge all of you to join us
after this talk to continue the
activities that will be going on in the
Peace Center this evening with no
further ado here's known
I guess it's not considered good form to
start by admonishing your audience but I
don't think it's a time for cheering in
fact it's not easy to talk about this
topic at all when we are just short of a
decision that's going to mean the
slaughter of tens if not hundreds of
thousands of people and that may set a
large part of the world in flames and
that's exactly what is soon going to
happen I suppose there's still
possibilities that it may be averted but
right now they look pretty slim well as
I say it's not easy to talk about it
calmly but since I really can't think of
much else to do that's what I will
proceed to do for what it's worth at
least we can try to understand what's
going on and use such understanding as
we can get as a basis of making some
reasonable decision about how to respond
to this and many other things like it
that are going to follow when Saddam
Hussein invaded Kuwait on August 2nd
there were two responses and they were
both on press they were both very strong
and pretty much unprecedented one
response which went through the United
Nations was sanctions and embargo and
those sanctions were of unprecedented
severity there's been nothing remotely
like them even in cases much worse than
this latest crime of saddam hussein's
the other response was preparation for
war quick preparation for war within a
day or two that preparation for war had
nothing to do with the annexation of
quate in fact it took place well before
the annexation so it had to do with the
invasion and at the time that it took
place there was essentially nothing to
distinguish Saddam Hussein's invasion of
Kuwait from for example
George Bush's invasion of Panama a
couple of months earlier which was
probably more bloody and destructive now
these two responses separate world
opinion quite substantially the first
response had pretty broad support at
least in the industrial world the
sanctions and sanctions of course means
negotiations sanctions means that you
put pressure on through some economic
means leading to a negotiated settlement
of some kind and diplomacy there's
another word for diplomacy it's called
linkage that word is a new one that was
kind of invented here and we're supposed
to be against it but it's just another
word for deplored diplomacy diplomacy
means you know you consider relevant
issues and you try to reach some
solution to them but since we're
supposed to be against it a new word was
necessary and that's linkage which is
bad and therefore everybody's against
linkage the so the first response is
sanctions and diplomacy equals linkage
and that had pretty broad support and
what was surprising about it is not that
it took place because there's often
broad support for broad opposition to
aggression but that it could get
implemented that sanctions could be
implemented which is rare and also that
they were so severe which is also very
rare the second response preparation for
war that was very limited in fact it was
limited to the United States and England
with very weak support from others also
the family dictatorships that run the
Gulf states they're in favor of it and
Israel's in favor of it but aside from
but it's basically a two member
partnership US and England and if you
look at the military structure you'll
notice that two military forces are
under a command structure to fight and
the others are kind of hanging around
the periphery to the extent that they're
at all the other major countries in the
world didn't want to do with it the
European community in Japan the other
two major power centers European
community outside of England made it
pretty clear at once that this was none
of their business they were not going to
support it even finance
in the third world very split much of it
is in fact against the any of the
responses in the air at the Arab world
there's a sharp division it's been noted
and it's worth paying attention to that
the division in the Arab world pretty
much has to do with the extent to which
a country has some degree of
responsiveness and open this to public
opinion by and large the more a country
has some form of pluralism and elements
of democracy it tends to be opposed to
the US presence and the Gulf the
countries that are more in support of it
are the ones that are more repressive
narrower have no openings that's pretty
much the case and it's been noticed the
New York Times specialist on the Middle
East Judith Miller pointed out that the
countries that have which he called
nascent democratic movements are opposed
to the US presence and administration
spokesmen have also noticed it and I've
spoken about it and I've pointed out
that there their conclusion from that is
that we have to strike fast because if
you especially if you let things run
into the Islamic religious periods
around March no the Ramadan and the
pilgrimage then even the totalitarian
states have a tough time keeping a lid
on public opinion and therefore the
whole thing may collapse so the
conclusion is strike fast and it's only
the same conclusions are drawn about the
homefront unless you strike fast
there'll be an expression of public
opinion well you can draw your own
conclusions from that both both the
lessons that it teaches about statecraft
and the prospects for action anyhow
there were those divisions George Bush
likes to talk about how it's the world
against Saddam Hussein which is
something of an exaggeration it
certainly is the industrial world and
parts of the rest against Saddam Hussein
but it's also in this respect in the
world against George Bush or to be more
precise against George Bush
and whoever happens to be sitting in 10
Downing Street at the moment varies but
it's the u.s. British coalition that's
pretty much breaking with world opinion
on that and has been from the beginning
now that raises a number of questions we
want to understand why the United
Nations was able to act which is very
unusual why the actions were so
unprecedented in severity as they were I
can't think of another case where there
was an embargo on food for example even
in much worse cases than this
and of course the crucial question is
why the United States and England are
alone aside from the family
dictatorships in the Gulf pretty much
alone well let's hold those questions in
the back of our minds for a second and
be clear about what in fact happened
next what happened next is that a meet
within days of the invasion well before
the annexation the United States moved
decisively to undercut the possibility
that sanctions might be effective that
was done instantly the immediate
response from Washington was to dispatch
to announce the sending of a huge
expeditionary force now a deterrent
force largely offshore that could be
kept in place for a long time long
enough for sanctions to take effect and
these sanctions are very likely to take
effect - it's two major reasons for that
one is their unprecedented severity and
the other is that the usual sanctions
busters namely the United States and
England and their allies happen to be on
board this time and vigorously on board
so it's not like South Africa so this
time it's very likely that the sanctions
would work but of course it takes time
for sanctions to work and a huge
Expeditionary Force can't be kept there
more than a couple of weeks or maybe
months at the outside furthermore
there's this problem that I mentioned
before you can't keep the troops too
long or the Arab world blows up because
nobody likes it cause they got to do it
fast that wouldn't be a problem with the
deterrent force so the purpose certainly
the effect and the predict
will affect so I assume the purpose of
announcing right off that there would be
a huge Expeditionary Force that must
have been it's the effect obviously was
and the purpose must have been to
undercut sanctions to make sure that
they can't work and within the first
couple of days it was clear that
sanctions were not an option
well what about diplomacy the other
aspect of the peaceful means prescribed
by international law sanctions and
diplomacy diplomatic opportunities began
to crop up from very quick very quickly
within a week or two by the end of
August there were several that look
pretty significant including Iraqi
offers that were regarded by high US
officials as serious and negotiable the
offers at that time basically had to do
with as you've all heard plenty of times
by now with two uninhabited islands in
the Gulf and with this particularly
filled the room I love oil field this
oil fields about 98 percent inside Iraq
crosses a disputed border and Iraq
wanted control of the whole thing the or
the uninhabited islands they have to do
with access to the Gulf the imperial
settlement imposed by England was set up
in such a way that Iraq is basically
landlocked and access to the Gulf would
involve control over those two islands
there could be lots of ways of working
this out you know leasing or whatever
you know much harder problems than that
have been settled through negotiations
and a settlement along those lines
looked feasible was it feasible well we
don't know because the United States
rejected it flat out out of hand the
only way you can find out if a proposal
is serious is to pursue it obviously and
rejecting it out of hand was a way of
ensuring that you there wouldn't be
serious in fact it was probably an
expression of fear that it might be
serious that the New York Times had a
pretty remarkable story Thomas Friedman
the diplomatic correspondent which that
means essentially the State Department
spokesman at the Times that's the nature
of that office he had a quite a
perceptive article I thought I think
was around August 22nd in which he said
that the administration wants to to
prevent the diplomatic track from being
pursued because of fear that pursuit of
the diplomatic track might defuse the
crisis in with his words in by offering
a few token gains for saddam hussein
namely and then he mentioned them a
couple of uninhabited islands and some
you know border rectification and you
don't want to defuse the crisis and when
he can have a neat war with a couple
hundred thousand people killed
apparently so that the the times
actually had this offer leaked to it and
suppressed it and it was only released
and then marginally when it was then
leaked to a suburban newspaper in New
York Newsday which publicly very
prominently on the front page that was
all over the news stands in New York and
he had at least have dismissive mention
of it in the back pages the next day
well since that time there have been
repeated offers the most recent one
that's been made public at least was on
J was disclosed on January 2nd again in
Newsday the reporter it's good reporter
in Newsday new troice Washington bureau
who's been following this topic very
closely on January 2nd he reported that
the US officials had disclosed and that
there had been an Iraqi offer a couple
of days earlier and that offer was to
withdraw completely from Kuwait in
return for a pledge not to attack the
withdrawing forces and to reach
Arrangements on so or settled there some
some things kind of vague you know to do
something about two issues to major
regional issues one of them the issue of
the arab-israeli conflict particularly
the state of the Palestinians and the
second issue was weapons of mass
destruction in the region so in return
for some kind of Security Council
commitment
- do you deal with those two issues
there could be complete withdrawal well
was that offer serious we don't know
because the United States dismissed it
instantly again hi State Department
officials thought of it thought it would
describe that as a serious pre
negotiating position as an indication
that Iraq wants to withdraw from Kuwait
and noted specifically that it didn't
say anything about the border issues
dropped them well that one didn't get
much publicity
the New York Times however which didn't
report that did report the same day a
meeting between Yasser Arafat and Saddam
Hussein in which RF said that they had
agreed that Saddam Hussein had made in a
proposal back on August 12th to withdraw
or at least to link Iraq all these
things are kind of a two linked Iraqi
withdrawal to withdrawal from other
occupied Arab territories that means
Syria and Israel from Lebanon and Syria
and Israel from the Syrian Golan Heights
and the West Bank and Gaza Strip and
according to the January 2nd report
January 3rd at times this was now
weakened to just at a commitment to deal
with those issues so withdrawal in
response to a commitment to deal with
those issues
well that was also rejected anyhow two
weeks before the deadline things looked
like this the contours of a possible
settlement were Iraqi withdrawal from
queit in return for a pledge not to
attack the withdrawing forces and a
commitment to settle regional issues no
settlement of them just a commitment to
settle a settlement that was rejected so
we don't know if that was serious the
all of that is indicative of a strong
opposition to diplomacy very strong
opposition to diplomacy these are
certainly well within the range of
negotiable positions but the United
States didn't want to hear them and they
were flat-out rejected and therefore we
haven't any idea and we'll never know
whether that offered a way of avoiding a
major catastrophe that has continued up
until
just a couple of hours ago last night
France made a proposal at the Security
Council for a Iraq calling for complete
and rapid Iraqi withdrawal from quoit in
return for and then comes wording vague
wording about calling an international
conference at an appropriate moment I am
saying win but sometime or other calling
it a commitment to call an international
conference at an appropriate moment to
consider the Palestinian issue in the
arab-israeli conflict that was the
proposal that was flat-out rejected by
the United States instantly the United
States and Britain rejected it outright
also the Soviet Union but you know at
this point the Soviet leadership and
stand on their heads and sing Yankee
Doodle if they thought they could get
American support so that's irrelevant
but England in the United States
instantaneously rejected it on the usual
grounds you know linkage meaning
diplomacy and you can't reward
aggressors and all this posturing now
what actually what the UN Ambassador the
American UN Ambassador said Thomas
Pickering he said you can't accept this
because it doesn't keep to the UN
resolutions on Iraq and quate and he's
technically correct about that the
wording is not drawn from those
resolutions it's drawn from a different
UN a decision Security Council decision
namely it's drawn from a security key
from a a Security Council decision on
December 20th of last year which I
definitely nothing to do with Iraq it
had to do with protection of the rights
of Palestinians under Israeli occupation
it was a resolution which called for I
think 681 which called for is recalled
on Israel to observe the Geneva
Conventions and to stop deporting people
and to protect the rights of
Palestinians under occupation
now that resolution was passed
unanimously the United States have voted
for it too and attached then came
something kind of unusual
attached to that resolution was a as a
codicil a statement attached to it which
said not in the resolution but attached
to it which said members of the Security
Council agree that in the interests of
peace they will proceed at an
appropriate moment that's the crucial
wording they will proceed at an
appropriate moment to consider call for
a an international conference to deal
with the issue in order to reach peace
now why wasn't that in the resolution
well because if that phrase had been in
the resolution in the United States
would have vetoed it right remember that
this had nothing to do with Iraq this
word Iraq or quate never got mentioned
in this resolution just had to do with
the Palestinians but the United States
was going to veto it if it said that at
some appropriate moment in the future
there would be unspecified when you know
at some moment in the future when it's
appropriate whatever that means
there might be an international
conference on the Palestinians that was
the case United States was going to veto
it nothing there about linkage and the
the French offer simply drew that
wording and tried to work it into a
resolution on Iraq
so pickering the ambassador was right
and saying the wording wasn't drawn from
Iraq resolutions but it was drawn from
another resolution or in addition to a
resolution just a couple of weeks
earlier well that's where we that
indicates the the depth of the
commitment of the United States not to
allow diplomacy to work you can't allow
it to work even in in any fashion
whatsoever you know even the weakest
gesture toward diplomacy has to be
blocked the us from the start insisted
that diplomatic contacts been limited to
delivery of an ultimatum you're allowed
to deliver them an ultimatum saying
capitulate or die that's diplomacy and
that's what George Bush calls going the
extra mile for peace and most of the
press including even people who ought to
know better like Fred Kaplan or the
globe
was a good reporter have described this
as a you know tremendous forthcoming
effort to explore every possible
diplomatic path and so on and so forth
fact is it was flat rejection of
diplomacy from the first instant now
those looking back we have the following
situation there were unprecedented
sanctions there were diplomatic options
the United States moved at once to
undercut the sanctions and moved at once
to undercut the diplomacy and has kept
to that position ever since well what
are the reasons for this you've heard
them ten thousand times we can't reward
aggressors you can't have linkage and so
on you know it just offends their moral
sensibilities to allow our aggressor to
get anything so therefore you know we
got a smash them in the face now you
know it really doesn't I don't we don't
have to waste any time discussing this
the only reason for even spending three
seconds on it is that this has been
accepted at face value virtually across
the spectrum so for example if you
listen to the congressional debate
you'll notice that I'm out and hear the
whole thing but just about everybody
maybe everybody every word I heard at
least accepted the legitimacy of this
and most of the press has accepted the
legitimacy of this as there's been very
little questioning of the rhetorical
stance this debate but the debate is
over
you know tactics is it good for us or is
it bad for us to pursue this just course
now because the rhetorical stance was
never challenged the debate was written
stricted to a tactical frame is it good
for us or is it bad for us to proceed
and in that frame the administration is
going to win obviously you know I mean
it's debatable and so you go along with
power of course if the rhetorical stance
had ever been challenged it would have
collapsed instantaneously and that would
have been the end of the debate because
it's impossible to uphold even one one
fragment of this position for three
seconds and the reason for that is very
simple in fact it's the reason is one of
logic basically the point of logic is
that you
can't uphold principle selectively if
you uphold some doctrine selectively
it's not a principle I mean that's
transparent and we don't ever doubt that
so for example when Saddam Hussein tells
us you know that he's agonizing over the
human rights abuses of the Israelis in
the occupied territories and he clutches
to his breasts the Amnesty International
report on Israeli atrocities which is
pretty awful incidentally or when he
tells us he's against annexation name
was against annexation of the Golan
Heights
we don't say he's a man of principle you
know you laugh and exactly the same
reasoning holds true when George Bush
tells us that he clutches to his breasts
the Amnesty International report on
Iraqi atrocities in quake but not a long
list of others you might think of and
that his aunt can't tolerate can't go to
sleep at night because of this thought
that an aggressor is not being punished
and so on and so forth I mean these are
jokes
incidentally in the third world my
impression we don't get much information
from the third world but my impression
is that they were regarded as jokes it's
kind of striking that until the last
couple of week days even people in the
third world didn't seem to think that
this was going to happen I was down at a
conference in Mexico last weekend and
nobody took it's you from people around
Latin America and nobody thought this
was for real they all thought you know
there's got it you know this is never
going to happen
I've people from the Middle East have
had the same reaction from right in the
region and I think the reason for that
is pretty simple when we hear Saddam
Hussein's posturing we laugh when they
hear George Bush's posturing they laugh
what they don't realize is that in the
United States and England people don't
laugh they take it seriously they don't
understand the deep totalitarian streak
in Western culture which means that you
can get by with this kind of posturing
and everybody takes it very seriously
and sombrely
and that's the kind of mistake that the
people in the third world have been
making for a long time in fact for 500
years ever since the European conquest
of the world began and I've paid quite a
cost for it and they're continuing to
pay a price
well now it's clear that it's for real
the that just it's it's instantaneous
I'm not gonna waste your time on it but
the United States is one of the leading
violators of all the principles that are
grandly proclaimed that's obvious you
know anybody who's opened their eyes in
the last 50 years or 100 years knows
that even the last year in fact and
therefore we don't have to argue any
further about these stands what about
the matter of linkage or sanctions well
supposedly we're not that we can't be
for sanctions because it'll take too
long why will it take too long well
there's the argument given by the
argument given by the administration and
by people in Congress is that if you one
argument is well if you wait for
sanctions to hold the coalition will
fall apart yeah that's interesting
that's possibly true incidentally but
that tells you something about the kind
of support that there is behind the u.s.
position the second argument is that
that sanctions will reward the aggressor
you know it just hurts our moral
sensibilities to sit by while we watch
the aggressor
you know benefit from what he's done we
got to move fast to stop this you know
our sensitive Souls from being seared by
this sight again that's not one you can
take very seriously either there are
other cases where there have been
sanctions very porous sanctions because
as I say the United States and England
and France and others regularly violate
them but take say South Africa the
occupation of Namibia was declared
illegal by the United Nations and the
World Court back around 19:00 late 60s
for years
the United States carried out what it
called quiet diplomacy and constructive
engagement 20 years in fact meanwhile
South Africa robbed the place
you know terrorized it used it as a base
for attacking its neighbors at a
terrific cost the UN Economic Commission
on Africa estimated the cost to the
neighbors alone
forget South Africa Namibia in the last
decade in the 80s they estimated it at
over sixty billion dollars and a half a
million and a half lives well meanwhile
our sensitive Souls weren't seared we
went along with nobody proposed bombing
South Africa and nobody bomb proposed
withholding food the sanctions you know
they were violated all over the place we
went on with diplomacy there was finally
a settlement with plenty of reward for
the aggressor plenty of linkage you know
linkage all the way up to Cuba and
everybody thought that was great you
know a great achievement of diplomacy
and the same is true in case after case
after case when George Shultz tried to
broker Israel's withdrawal from Lebanon
after a completely unprovoked attack in
which maybe 20,000 civilians were killed
when he tried to that was a partial
withdrawal from Lebanon plenty of reward
for the aggressor and plenty of linkage
so you know Syria was ordered to get out
not no negotiations with Syria just give
him orders
that's linkage with a vengeance same was
true after Israel's invasion of Sinai
back in 1956 which the United States
didn't like that time so kicked them out
but again with plenty of rewards for the
aggressor that's just standard so this
condition just can't be taken seriously
I mean serious people can't waste a
moment on this so let's not the there's
a conclusion that follows from this
incidentally the conclusion that follows
is that no reason has been offered for
going to war and I mean no reason
there has none whatsoever there's been
simply no argument the reason is that
every single argument is transparently
fraudulent not complicated for a trivial
fraud and that means whatever is going
on has nothing to do with the reasons
that are being presented some other
thing well let's come back to the
original questions why the
why did why where the sanctions
implemented well one reason maybe the
answer to that is also trivially simple
the sanctions were implemented because
the United States for once permitted it
usually the United States doesn't permit
the UN to carry out its peacekeeping
role that's why it doesn't carry it out
for the last 20 years the United States
is far in the lead in vetoing Security
Council resolutions in second place is
the other one of the righteous Avengers
in the Gulf Britain mainly because of
their protection of the racist states of
southern Africa between them the United
States and England which are now
standing on high principle account for
about four-fifths of the Security
Council vetoes during these last 20
years in third place well behind it's
France and in fourth place is the United
Union well you know there's we're now
told over and over again the one of the
really important things is this great
New World Order which you know finally
you know have peace and the UN will be
able to function because the Soviet
Union is out of the clost the Cold War
and therefore they're not going to block
the UN anymore well you know it takes
three minutes to figure out who's been
blocking the UN I should say the same is
true in the General Assembly and there's
not the slightest reason to suppose that
with the Soviet Union out of the game
the United States and Britain will
suddenly call off their campaign against
international law and against the United
Nations don't make any sense why should
they think I'll carry it out more
vigorously there's less less than the
way there's no prospects for a new world
order or a great new era in fact quite
the contrary I should say incidentally
that in this case too
I think if you take a careful look
you'll notice that the United States
also undercut the peacekeeping function
of the United Nations but in a more
complex way usually it does just does it
by vetoes straight vetoes so nothing can
happen in this case
the United Nations did move towards
sanctions and the United States as I
said undercut that instantly undercut
the sanctions option and undercut the
diplomacy option that's undercutting the
peacekeeping mission of the UN there
were lots of threats and pressure and
cajole Rianne finally what in effect
happened is the UN washed its hands of
the matter this famous UN resolution
that was passed basically says nothing
it says use any necessary means doesn't
tell you what necessary means or they
can be diplomacy or sanctions or for
those guys who want to kill a lot of
people they can be kill a lot of people
but that's a decision for the individual
states to take there's no UN resolution
that uses any phrase like minimal use of
force or anything of that kind
the UN has mechanism Security Council
has mechanisms to call for military
force it specifically didn't use them
and the United States incidentally
didn't want it to use them because those
UN resolutions were intended as nothing
more than a weapon against Congress so
that you could turn to Congress people
in Congress and say you guys aren't as
patriotic as Malaysia or something and
that's that's it now this whole record
is one of simply undercutting the United
Nations in a slightly different fashion
than the usual one why were the
sanctions of such unprecedented severity
well that's easy to answer to it's
because of tremendous US pressure u.s.
is a scary place and people don't stand
up against it it's dangerous and
frightening and if the u.s. is putting a
lot of print also powerful and if US is
putting pressure on people tend to go
along I'm gonna stand up against you
don't stand up against a violent lawless
terrorist state and what happened is the
sanctions were imposed again that's not
explicit there's nothing explicit in the
UN fact the UN resolutions don't even
call for enforcing sanctions if you
actually read the wording but it was
interpreted the US way block everything
including force so that answers the
first set of questions
very simple the UN could act because the
United States for once permitted it to
instead of blocking it as usual the
reaction was particularly harsh because
the United States twisted a lot of arms
and scared a lot of people the and
that's about all there is to it as far
as the first questions are concerned
what about the more interesting ones the
why are the United States and England
isolated on this issue well that's
important to look at here we got here
you have to look a little more carefully
at the what's going on so let's let's
start with this latest Iraqi offer
disclosed by US officials remember to
withdraw from quate in return for
agreements on two major issues regional
issues at the arab-israeli conflict and
weapons of mass destruction why won't
the US permit that well I've already
mentioned that the u.s. is opposed to an
international conference quite
independently of anything having to do
with Iraq and in fact we know that
because the US has been opposed to a
international conference long before
Iraq invaded Kuwait so the argument that
we're now opposed to it because of
linkage that can't be true we were
opposed to it before quite apart from
the fact that we standardly reward
aggressors even much worse cases than
this so that's not the answer what is
the answer well the answer to that is
also painfully simple the United States
is opposed to a diplomatic settlement of
the arab-israeli conflict and it's been
opposed to it for a long time and it's
isolated on that the last vote at the
United Nations last year was a hundred
and fifty one to three the three where
the United States Israel and Dominica
now that's the kind of unanimity you
never get at the United all the NATO
allies voted against this everybody did
I mean maybe one or two countries were
sleeping or something but it was
basically the world against George Bush
you know and by again by a large much
larger majority than the world against
Saddam Hussein well that's why we're and
that's why it's been for 20 years the
United States and Israel have been
essentially alone in blocking a
political
settlement of the arab-israeli conflict
which has been supported by the whole
world well that tells you why they're
against the NIR National Conference
what's going to happen at an
international conference any no matter
how you pick the people you pick them as
you like there's no way to must you pick
just Dominica at an international
conference there's going to be pressure
and that'll probably change you know I
probably changed the day after the vote
when they paid them off the at any
international conference there's going
to be pressure for a diplomatic
settlement and the United States doesn't
want a diplomatic settlement therefore
there can't be an international
conference period nothing to do with
linkage nothing to do with Iraq nothing
to do with anything
that's why it's that's the way it's been
for years the United States has been
vetoing Security Council resolutions
voting virtually alone against General
Assembly resolutions undercutting every
possible initiative this has been going
on since 1977 t71 nothing new about it
that's what our blocking of the piece of
the diplomatic process on this even has
a technical name in the United States
it's called the peace process we're
pursuing the peace process meaning
blocking every conceivable possibility
to get peace and in fact occasionally
you get an article like you know we'll
say something where well the the the
Russians are member an article in New
York Times saying the Russians are
trying to come aboard you know they're
trying to get to join the diplom of the
peace process meaning maybe they're
going to accept the u.s. position in
isolation from the rest of the world you
know if they do that they'll be on the
team team being US by definition every
US was off the team well that's the way
it's been for a long time so therefore
there can't be an international
conference and therefore we go we go to
war what about the second issue the
issue of weapons of mass destruction
well refusal of linkage on this one is
particularly remarkable because this is
a disarmament issue and disarmament
issues are always settled in a regional
or global context I mean that's not even
in dispute right of course disarmament
issues are settled in a in a broader
context regional or maybe
global everyone is but we reject it in
this case and once again that rejection
though it's claimed to be based on
linkage has nothing to do with Iraq's
conquest of quate and it's easy to prove
that we improve it very easily by simply
noticing that the United States also
opposed the diplomatic settlement of
that problem before the Iraq invasion of
Kuwait in fact last April when Saddam
Hussein was still George Bush's great
friend and favored trading partner at
that last April
Iraq made an offer to destroy its
non-conventional weapons to destroy its
biological and chemical weapons and that
was turned down by the United States the
United States responded and turned it
down because Saddam Hussein insisted
that this be done in a regional context
that is that Israel destroyed its
nuclear weapons and its biological and
chemical weapons well you know that's
not entirely unreasonable one might
think but the United States rejected it
and the terms of the rejection are worth
listening to
the official State Department rejection
said they welcomed Saddam Hussein's
offer to destroy his own weapons but
that can't be linked the United States
rejects any link to other weapons issues
the other weapons issues were left
unspecified but of course everybody
knows what that means that means
Israel's nuclear weapons which they've
had for at least twenty years probably a
couple hundred of them now you can't
mention that if you look at the US
diplomatic record you'll notice that no
spokesperson for the government ever
refers to Israeli nuclear weapons I mean
everybody knows they've got them you
know that's not even a question but you
can't refer to them
why can't you refer to them well as a
reason for that in American law
according to amendments to the foreign
aid legislation back in the 70s it's
illegal under American law to give any
aid at all including economic aid to any
country that's engaged in clandestine
nuclear weapons development so therefore
if you concede that Israel has nuclear
weapons all aid to Israel has been
illegal for years and you can't concede
that so therefore you don't mention
Israeli nuclear weapons but in order to
preserve Israel's right to continued
nuclear weapons development without
mentioning it of course we reject the
possibility of treating Saddam Hussein's
military Arsenal's through diplomatic
means which is the right way to do it
and we go to war
that's the other that's the other
element notice there are three issues
here that are linked one is Iraqi
withdrawal from quate another settlement
of the arab-israeli conflict and other
regional security problems and a third
the problem of Saddam Hussein's
threatening military Arsenal's there
appears to be a diplomatic approach to
every one of those three issues the
United States is opposed to a diplomatic
settlement of each of those issues and
therefore it's opposed to linking them
very simple that's the answer to why
we're opposed to linkage meaning
diplomacy and why we go to war well that
gives you more understanding of what's
going on the Britain is with us on this
alone virtually alone except even it on
these Arabs really confident Britain's
not with us in fact nobody is except
Israel well that leaves basically
they're really the serious question why
are the United States and Britain alone
on this issue why is it the world versus
the United States and England which it
pretty much is that's a serious question
because it's going to blow up a large
part of the world very shortly
maybe getting started right now so it's
worth trying to understand it
well when you turn to the other
questions are really trivial I mean
every question I've mentioned so far
shouldn't strain the intelligence of a
ten-year-old if it's not in the front
pages of the newspaper it's because
they're trying hard not to understand it
there's nothing subtle about this and
you don't have to have any complicated
knowledge of world affairs or be able to
think through hard arguments or anything
you have to know anything everything you
know everything that I just said is
basically Elementary and there should be
much confusion about it however this
other question why the United States and
England are alone that's harder there
you really have to speculate you know
you have to try to figure out what's
behind policy decisions and so on and it
is speculation so you could argue but
speculation doesn't have to be totally
uninformed
you know there's as evidence
there's evidence from history and
there's evidence from the current the
current world situation how am i doing
on time okay so let's take a look at
those at those two questions those two
issues we know something about those on
the matter of history there's some very
this again pretty obvious points there
there was an imperial settlement in that
region and that imperial settlement was
imposed by the United States and England
it was in fact imposed in such a way
that they would be the beneficiaries of
it given that fact it's not too
surprising to see that those are the two
countries that are girding up for war
and the gulf while everybody else keeps
their distance now the history of this
goes back to the early part of the
century originally it was England in
France you know they sort of had the
they ran the region by the first world
war the United States was becoming a big
actor in international affairs and it
wanted to get in - so there was a
British French US division around you
know by the 20s and the 30s after the
Second World War the United States
essentially took over the you know the
relations of power were such that the
United States was just overwhelmingly
powerful France was kicked in the pants
immediately they were kicked out of the
arrangement on the grounds that France
was an enemy state and therefore the
agreements with it the treaties and so
on didn't mean anything it was an enemy
state because it had been under German
occupation so I got rid of France left
England in the United States the the
British tried to hang on and the United
States was not allowing them very much
there was a lot of conflict between
Britain and the United States in the
late 40s in the early 50s it was pretty
much resolved by the mid 50's under the
dictates of the stronger partner you
know I mean the United States wanted to
keep Britain in the game and the reason
for that was stated on cautiously in a
secret discussion by a high Kennedy
official which
got Declassified he described England as
our lieutenant and then he said the
fashionable word is partner and I don't
tell the British about this they're
supposed to have delusions of
partnership but you know in secret there
are lieutenants so we want to keep them
viable that's called the special
relationship and by the fifties it was a
British an anglo-american condominium
with the u.s. calling most of the shots
of course now there's an earlier history
needless to say and even if nobody
remembers it here they probably remember
it elsewhere so just in the case of of
that right after the First World War the
British were having some problems
holding together the Empire Britain was
weakened by the First World War
and that meant it was kind of hard to
keep the lid on things and they had to
get pretty violent in fact to do it
that's when the Amritsar massacre took
place in India in 1919 with about 400
unarmed protestors massacred there were
similar problems in Iraq and England
didn't have the the manpower to put it
down and have the troops at that point
so they decided to innovate and turn to
terror bombing of villages for the first
time which is cheaper you know I don't
need a lot of force for that now the
also the terror bombing of villages was
used even to collect collect taxes from
tribesmen and that sort of thing and it
was pretty effective but it wasn't quite
enough the RAF Royal Air Force Middle
East Command in 1919 requested
authorization for the use of chemical
weapons as again here's a quoting
against recalcitrant Arabs as experiment
now chemical weapons that means poison
gas at the time that was regarded with
the ultimate horror you know this was
right after the first world war it was
ultimate revulsion was poison gas so
they requested authorization to do that
the India office didn't think it was a
very bright idea they thought it would
have negative consequences but they were
overruled by the secretary of state at
the War Office who dismissed what he
called this squeamishness over the use
of gas
and he's declared himself to be strongly
in favor of the use of poisoned gas
against uncivilized tribes
that was Winston Churchill incidentally
one of the great moral heroes of the
West and it kind of went on from there
so you know there is an earlier history
but let's put that aside and turn to the
post Second World War period the US and
Britain pretty much had it under control
but there was a break there was a break
in 1953 when he ran tried to take
control of its own oil that was taken
care of with a CIA coup the big break
the serious one was in 1958 when Iraq
had a national and military nationalist
officers coup which overthrew a
dependent regime and took Iraq out of
the partially at least out of the
anglo-american condominium well that
caused a furor in Washington and London
one response was a Marine landing in
Lebanon the next day the next day to
prop up the regime there a second
response was parent authorization by
Eisenhower of the use of nuclear weapons
in case any unfriendly forces went into
quate third response was a set of
decisions by Britain in the United
States about how to handle the situation
and they the way equate at that time is
more loss of colony although they called
it independent and the British decided
that it would be a wise idea to give
Quaid at least nominal independence to
try to undercut the possibility that a
nationalist revolt might spread there
but however reserving the right to
intervene by force or as they put it
ruthlessly to intervene if anything goes
wrong no matter who's responsible and
the United States reserve the same right
for the rest of the region in fact they
jointly agreed that the oil fields of
Kuwait Saudi Arabia Bahrain and the
other Emirates that they'd be kept in
us-british hands they were very clear
about the reasons the reasons were and
they're important because they're still
operative and
like more operative than ever the
reasons were first Britain Britain which
had an ailing economy then worse now but
an ailing economy needed privileged
access to the oil of quate and crucially
to investments from quate in order to
prop up its economy which had to prop up
sterling which was extremely weak so
that was major condition now by the
early 1970s those very same
considerations were applying to the
United States the United States was
losing its world dominance in fact it
was seriously losing it from an economic
point of view and it began to need not
the oil so much but the profits from oil
oil creates huge profits and control
over those profits gives you a plenty of
power and the United States started
needing also of course control over oil
gives you a good deal of influence over
people who need oil it's a it's a lever
of world control you know a significant
lever but so you got several reasons one
access to the oil on preferential terms
to reliever of world control but three
just the profits alone they're necessary
and by the early 70s that was beginning
to be serious going back to 1958 for a
moment the National Security Council
that you know the highest planning body
in decisions that have now been
partially Declassified you there isn't
too much declassification of US records
incidentally because the Reagan
administration which had a kind of a
fascist element to it imposed very heavy
restrictions on declassification they
didn't want the public to be able to see
what's going on so things get
Declassified now with very heavy
restriction so much so that the State
Department historians all quit a few
months ago but anyhow enough went
through that you can see what was going
on the National Security Council decided
in 58 after the Iraqi coup that the US
should be prepared to use force if
needed in order to secure British and
American interests in the region in
queit and other parts of the region that
tells us a lot about what's going on now
as I say by the early seventies the u.s.
needed the investment
and beginning to need the access to the
oil as much as the British did at that
time we're a little behind him in this
in fact this is one of the really
there's been a very substantial capital
flow from the Gulf oil producers to
England in the United States other
places to that primarily England in the
United States and that's propped up
their financial institutions their
corporations and their general economies
just purchase of Treasury securities by
Saudi Arabia props up the American
economy in fact when the oil price goes
up what in fact happens is dollars shift
from one bank to another in New York and
pounds shift from one bank to another in
London to a large extent prices go up a
lot of petrol dollars but they get spent
and they get spent on manufacturing
firms and so on primarily in the in
England in the United States and a lot
of it goes straight to if they purchase
up parts of ailing banks and Treasury
securities and so on that's been a big
shot in the arm for the US and British
economies British for a long time in the
United States for the last 20 years
that's a good reason for keeping control
over this system these are all good
reasons that's one of the reasons why
the United States and England have not
been particularly opposed to rises in
the oil price in fact sometimes they
favored it after the big year
quadrupling of oil prices in the early
70s that actually improved the British
and American economies helped them the
balance of trade between the United
States and the oil producers improved in
the u.s. favor you know after the oil
price went up at quadrupled that's for
exactly the reasons I mentioned also the
rise in oil prices helps countries that
produce high cost oil they're two such
countries primarily the United States
and England the oil corporations knew
about Alaska oil a long time ago but it
wasn't profitable enough after the price
quadrupled in the early seventies it
became profitable so they started
producing it same with North Sea
soyal all that is good and also quite
apart from that the energy corporations
are all us I mean with some minor
exceptions they're basically us British
and their profits go up as the oil price
goes up so these are all parts of the
system important parts well you know
without going on you put all these
things together you see some pretty good
reasons why two countries are getting
ready to go to war just as they said
they were gonna do back in the late 50s
and probably since but we don't have
documents since we do have documents up
to then and we know what they say and
they make a lot of sense and you can
look at the record sense and see it
follows the same lines
well there's one final point to make
about this and here we really do
speculate that has to do with the
current world system and take a look at
what the current world system is like
you know there's a lot of talk about
this fabled new world order and there's
something to it you know there is there
are changes in the world in fact there
have been changes in the world for the
last 20 years and in important ones
about 20 years ago it was becoming quite
clear that economic power was diffusing
in u.s. domains there were it was
diffusing into three major power centers
German led Europe Japan and it's region
and the United States and its region the
United States is still the biggest you
know but not very much anymore and in
fact the Reaganite policies severely
harmed the American economy and it's
going to those costs have not yet come
due but they're serious the Vietnam War
harmed the American economy was very
costly to the United States very
beneficial to the industrial rivals of
the United States and all of that stuff
changed the structure of the world
economy that's major part of the new
world or three major powers the u.s.
especially after Reagan now deeply in
debt and much weakened that's part of
the new world order what about the
Russian what about the disappearance of
the Soviet Union well by the mid
seventies it was pretty clear that the
Russians were in bad trouble in fact
their military expenditures started
leveling off exactly the opposite of
what we were told at the time but the
CIA is now conceded it and by a couple
of years later it's pretty clear
they're finished and the effect of that
is there's several effects to that one
effect is rhetorical since 1917 every
sing every American intervention
anywhere has been in defense against the
Russians that's you know like when the
US began support fascist Italy back in
1922 as they did that was in defense
against the Russians and everything up
until then has been in defense against
the Russians by about nineteen eighty
eight that becomes impossible I mean
even the most fertile imagination you
can't say we're defending ourselves
against the Russians so you need other
excuses that's one change new rhetorical
framework the invasion of Panama was
historic in this respect I was just like
everything that's been going on for
hundreds and hundred years and most
respects but it was different in that
you couldn't say we were defending
ourselves against the Russians so one
change is rhetorical and that's
happening again in the Gulf a second
change is more significant the Soviet
Union and its empire are now opened up
freely to Western exploitation that is
they're reverting to what they were
before 1917 quasi colonial dependencies
of the industrial West and that's a big
change but of course the United States
and Britain are not ahead in that game
Germany's ahead and Japan when it
decides to get into it will be ahead but
written in the United States are not
capital rich countries they can't do
that so that's the second development
not good for the United States and
Britain third major development is that
although the world is tri-polar
economically it's got one military power
and furthermore that military power is
now a lot more free to use military
force than ever before because there's
no deterrent any longer Soviet deterrent
is gone ten fifteen years ago the United
States could not have sent massive
conventional armies to the Middle East
now I can do anything it feels like that
gives the u.s. a lot more freedom to use
force well you put these things together
and you get a certain picture everything
I say about the United States is also
true of England but at a much lower
scale as well put them behind I'll keep
the lieutenant out of the story the the
you know we have three major military
powers three major economic powers
one major military power that military
power doesn't any longer have the
economic base to carry off intervention
well some consequences follow and
they're drawn so for example when Deputy
Secretary of State Lawrence Eagleburger
was testifying to Congress a couple of
weeks ago about the new world order he
said the new world order will be based
on what he called a kind of new
invention in the art of diplomacy namely
we carry out intervention other people
pay for it well who's going to pay for
it British and the Germans and the
Japanese are not that happy about paying
for it they're quite happy to see the
United States and England go down the
tube so they win the second world war
they're not gonna pay for it and there's
only one other big third big big source
of capital in the world that's the Gulf
oil producers in fact that's the way you
make the Germans and the Japanese pay
for it via the oil price coming back
here okay
so that's the way you pay for it however
notice that there is a shared interest
with Germany and Japan and the whole
industrial world namely somebody has to
keep the third world under control this
war against the world that's been going
on for the last 500 years it still has
to go on and somebody's got to be there
to make sure it works
you know you try with the IMF and all
that stuff that's cost-effective but
sooner or later you need the Marines you
know or the b-52s or something and the
United States is the only country they
can do it
Britain secondarily but primarily the
United States so somebody has to play
the enforcer role and that's got to be
us and that is now being openly
discussed in the International Business
press for example where it's pointed out
that the US must play even more than
before what's called the mercenary role
the United States has to be the Hessians
the guys who put down who keep the third
world under control and other people pay
for if there's a diplomatic settlement
it's of no particular advantage to the
United States if there's a capitulation
to force it's of considerable advantage
to the United States it shows that our
comparative advantage is important our
comparative advantages in the use of
force
certainly not in diplomacy we've always
been against diplomacy but not even
anymore economically
however force we rank supreme if you can
show that forces the crucial device for
controlling the world
you're better off and I think that's
another reason why you got to power
sitting there on the Gulf incidentally
the oil producers recognize this from
their own point of view a couple of
weeks ago there was a days ago in fact
there was a an article in The Wall
Street Journal which quoted a high Gulf
official as saying that it's any reason
for his son to die and quate because we
have our white slaves to do that he
hadn't looked very carefully at the skin
color of the mercenaries there and he'd
also forgotten for a moment that the
guys with the guns are going to call the
shots and if he gets out of line he'll
learn that very fast but apart from that
it's sort of true they're our last
comment there are domestic developments
in the United States that are tending in
the same direction it's not a big secret
that the you know so-called
infrastructure is collapsing the
educational system is collapsing the
health systems collapsing the inner
cities are being destroyed you may have
seen the statistics that were published
a couple days ago on prison population
in the United States the United States
is way ahead of anybody else in per
capita prison population way ahead of
South Africa and Russia which used to be
up ahead of us for a black male the
probability of being in prison in the
United States is four times as high as
in South Africa under apartheid that
tells you something all of this reflects
an internal third world you know that's
business is worried I mean are worried
because too many people are in jail
they're worried because half the jobs in
the next decade or so have to be filled
by blacks and Hispanics and if you keep
them in jail and in you know
concentration camps called cities and so
on they're not going to be able to do
any of the work that you need done so
they're expecting a big shortage of
skilled labor and that means that
transnational corporations are going to
shift those operations that involve
skilled labor overseas to where there is
skilled labor educated populations and
so on
that means everything from research and
management and so on to product
development and you know guys to push
buttons on computers and so on and so
forth what happens to the United States
well you know maybe these guys can't do
research but they can truck around the
desert so they can be Hessians that's
another factor that's pressing in the
same direction now that's pretty much
what the future is gonna look like if it
goes on the way it does it's not for
their usual victims it's like always for
the citizens of the mercenary States
it's also not particularly attractive if
they let it happen and it might happen
that's the way things are moving to
another thing that's going on in the
Gulf well what about policy choices your
policy choices depend on what your goals
are if the goal had been to get Iraq out
of quate and to settle you know to
reduce regional tensions and to move you
know make a move towards a slightly more
decent world you would use sanctions and
diplomacy and the peaceful means
required by international law if the
goal however is to firm up the mercenary
enforcer role and to establish the rule
of force in the world that's the goal
then the policy choices that the Bush
administration has picked have a certain
chilling logic through them
thank you very much No just for your
information I'd like everybody in 10 to
50 to realize there are actually more
people that are outside of 210 to 50 who
are watching this event this evening and
for those who are outside and are still
concerned about whether they can be able
to make the necessary questions or
comments we will allow these to be
written down and these can be passed to
the Usher and then will be brought here
and randomly selected for for anyone
who's outside 10 to 50 the second
announcement I'd like to make before
getting on with our second speaker is
that we have the specific list of events
that will be taking place in the Peace
Center this evening and rich Cohen will
read those out thanks this is a
continuation in some cases of the
workshops that took place yesterday
there will be a table on the third floor
of the Student Center when the group
moves over to the Student Center after
the beginning of the question and
answers session the question and answer
session will continue in the Student
Center and sometime toward the beginning
to the middle that question and answer
session people will break up into these
working groups organizing groups there
will be three small group discussions
one led by Geetha from MIT one led by
David from MIT one led by Marcy from
Brandeis in the in probably in the
private dining rooms on the third floor
the gender gap working group by real men
of Boston and ecological transportation
group will not be meeting tonight but
there'll be a sign-up sheet for those
activities a sign-up sheet so that you
can get connected with the next meeting
of those groups the ecological group is
meeting Friday the newspaper creation
workshop of a daily anti-war organizing
newspaper that will take place with
Steve Penn from MIT political art and
painting Mary Ann Donnelly from MIT
political organizing that will be me and
that will be combined with some other
people who were working on the direct
action group the letter writing the
letter writing and court and computer
communication
task force Erica from Brandeis and John
from Harvard there'll be the direct
action meeting the direct action meeting
will be announced a little bit later
when we get over there and then there's
going to be an MIT caucus not all the
people here here from here from MIT but
those of you who are penlow will have a
meeting over there we're still here in
this room everybody we're not going over
there yet
we still have one more speaker before we
go over to the Student Center and I'll
introduce Michael Albert and here our
second speaker for the evening is
perhaps probably the most notorious
student organizer from MIT he was
actually at one point the MIT
undergraduate Association president he
co-founded the south end pressed and the
Z magazine and period here he is Michael
Albert
[Applause]
when I came here 25 years ago it was to
be a physicist I I loved it that's
pretty good at it I was comfortable with
it this was probably the best place in
the country to or at least one of the
best places in the country to become
educated as a physicist when I left here
I had been educated to be something else
I was a person instead of a physicist I
was just a feeling thinking person I
wound up a revolutionary that's what I
left here as that's what I was taught to
be I was taught by know and by the
social movements of the time
a revolutionary meaning a person who
felt that the reason why we had the
atrocity of Vietnam the reason why we
had the atrocity that the civil rights
movement confronted and that the women's
movement confronted that the other
movements of that time confronted was
because the basic underlying
institutions of our society and that
they had to be changed the reason I was
notorious while I was here it's because
of my response to things that went on in
this institution at that time and
they're undoubtedly parallel things that
go on today one of those things for
example was a project to stabilize
helicopters it was ostensibly to
stabilize helicopters so that they could
fly over Detroit and evaluate traffic
patterns when we broke on to the airport
where those helicopters were and
photographed them we came back with the
photographs we were able to prove what
we said all along which was that the
helicopters were gunships and that the
stabilization process was to be able to
shoot the peasants and the fields in
Vietnam more accurately Jesse said
studying War no more last night and we
tried to do that another project that
was going on here at MIT at the time was
to develop a radar system no radar
system that could guide bombs so that
the bombs would literally be smart and
find their target better we didn't know
about that we found out about it later
when those smart bombs were a part of
the worst bombing run
the Vietnam War it is conclusion other
projects included ideological projects
associated with justifying the war one
of the faculty people here if the oldest
solar pool would regularly interrogate
Vietnamese prisoners my response to all
of this and much more was a great deal
of anger anger which you can probably
already perceive here tonight and at
that time I allowed that anger to show I
expressed it I screamed it when need be
and I demonstrated with it and that was
considered moderately insane and made me
notorious and in the 25 years since then
I have kept that anger down you know how
when you walk down the street over on
Boylston Street and you see somebody
grabbing food out of a garbage can or
somebody asks you for a quarter and
they're in pretty decrepit shape and you
try and keep going and you try and get
by it and you close yourself off to it a
little bit well for the 25 years between
then and now I've been a revolutionary
I've been an activist I've been involved
all the time with addressing the same
questions but I've also closed off a
little to the emotions and the anger and
the energy that you feel because of
those phenomena and the reason for that
is because of the relative absence of
large social movements which were
present when I was here at MIT and which
gave an outlet and the reason I'm in
quite a bit of turmoil tonight is
because some of those shields are
starting to come down and that's because
for example today there were 50,000
people in the streets of Seattle
protesting what's going on
it's because it's because if the reports
I'm hearing are correct there were three
or four thousand people occupying the
main postal center in the city of
Chicago what I want to do tonight is to
try and talk about the broader context
and the cause is and what we can do
about it with the intention that in
Boston in the coming days we'll have the
militants of those 3,000 people who are
in the postal office in Chicago and the
numbers of the 50,000 or 75,000 people
who are in the streets of Seattle
marching and we will be able to have an
impact on this city and on the nation in
that manner for me what's happening
right now as bad as it is as
unbelievably surreal as it is with this
deadline is really just one part of a
phenomenon that exists all the time and
it's the war of the developed West
basically the United States on the whole
third world and that's the thing that I
turned off my sensitivity to a little
bit in those 25 years and which roused
me so much then and is again I'm gonna
have a little trouble reading this but I
will it is an attempt to try and
encapsulate the scale and the magnitude
of the crimes that Nome has been
documenting for the last 25 years I over
the course of that time had been gnomes
publisher and I've not only read his
words but if often typeset them and laid
them out and the process often leaves me
throwing rocks at the sides of buildings
my own building regrettably there's no
social movement powerful enough during
that period of time to channel that kind
of energy recently I wrote something to
try in and encapsulate the scale of the
crimes that I feel go on in the world
and that I feel we have to address
suppose the hypothetical God got tired
of what we humans do to one another and
decided that from January 1st 1999
onward all corpses created by violence
or neglect anywhere in the free world
would cease to decompose anyone dying
for want of food or medicine anyone hunk
hung or garrotted to death
shot or beaten to death raped or bombed
to death anyone dying unjustly and
inhumanity in countries of the free
world would as a corpse persist without
decomposing and the permanent corpse
would then automatically enter a glass
walled cattle are attached to an
ethereal train traveling across the
United States state by state never
stopping one by one the corpses would be
loaded on the killing train and after
every thousand corpses piled in a new
car would hitch up and begin filling
also mile after mile The Killing train
would roll along each corpse viewed
through walls of transparent glass 200
new corpses a minute one new car every
five minutes day and night without pause
by the end of 1991 on its first birthday
The Killing Train would measure over
2,000 miles long traveling at 20 miles
an hour would take about five days to
pass through an intersection by the year
2000 assuming no dramatic change in
institutions and behavior the Train
would stretch from coast to coast seven
times it would take about six weeks from
the time its engine passed the Statue of
Liberty to when its caboose would go by
full of corpses preventable deaths every
death in they're preventable think our
young children somehow sometimes point
to a picture in a book or a magazine and
ask for an explanation tell me about a
tree a car a boat a train a big train
killing train try and answer that think
about the pain that radiates from the
Vietnam war monument with its 50,000
names
imagine the lost opportunity and lost
love and the network of negative
influences that radiates from the
unnecessary deaths engraved on that
monument now think about the killing
train
stretching from coast to coast and back
and forth and back and forth and back
and forth consider its impact not only
on those on board but on every person
that any of those corpses ever loved or
would have loved Federer would have fed
torta would have taught who rides the
killing train citizens of the third
world selling their organs for food
selling the babies to save their
families suffering disappearances
diseases starvation mass murder they
live in Brazil the Philippines El
Salvador South Africa and New York City
they are headed for the killing train
every day millions of them when 10
million people die when 10 million
children die yearly for lack of basic
medical care that the US could provide
at almost no cost in countries whose
economies Exxon and the Bank of America
have looted what can you call it other
than mass murder bloated diseased bodies
of victims who've murdered just as
surely as bullet riddled bodies tossed
into rivers by death squads denying
medicine is no less criminal than
supplying torture rocks and stealing
resources that's the background of
international relations at least as I
see it that made me a revolutionary
why does Bush want war it seems to me
that Bush wants war partly minimally I
suppose I should say it's obvious that
he doesn't want war because we oppose
violation of national sovereignty is
know made clear if we opposed violation
of national sovereignty we wouldn't
support the Israelis in their violation
of Lebanon's sovereignty we wouldn't
support Syria in their violation of it
we wouldn't support Turkey we wouldn't
support we wouldn't support the United
States and it's violation of Panama's
sovereignty of Grenada sovereignty of
South Africa of many countries
throughout the world that's not the
issue the price of oil isn't the issue
the control of the price of oil is a
serious issue insofar as the United
States is no longer a viable and a
serious economic force in the world as
it once was the control of oil is one
economic card that we can hold and we
want to keep holding it that's a
powerful reason but it's not sufficient
to explain the drive toward war it's
only sufficient to explain the desire to
get Hussein out of Kuwait I think the
desire drive toward war is explained by
something else which Noam also brought
up and that's the desire as he described
to have a new world order in which
American might is a function no longer
of in part economic power and in part
military power but basically entirely
military power for those who are old
enough paladin have gun will travel the
difference is that the people who pay
will pay because we have the gun also we
will force them to pay that's the future
Bush has in mind what what do people do
about this now I know that you all know
that what you do is you protest what you
do is you demonstrate what you do is you
march you rally you do civil
disobedience you educate your whole
teachings you talk to people I'd like to
provide what I hope will be some useful
lessons they're very simple they're
almost transparently obvious I think but
they're hard to keep in mind and they
can inform our activity and give us a
strength
help us in the period ahead the first
lesson the most trivial and obvious and
in many ways the most important and the
hardest to keep in mind is that
organizing works it really does work one
night when I came here in 1965 there
were anti-war demonstrations in Boston
they were small they were held at the
common they were minuscule compared to
what's happening right now and MIT
actually participated to a small extent
a small number of MIT students would go
over and throw rocks at the
demonstrators no lie that was about the
extent of MIT student participation in
anti-war demonstrations in the year 1964
in 1965 in 1969 as mentioned I was
elected the undergraduate Association
president at MIT the platform included
No More war research no more grades at
MIT
no more requirements open admissions for
working-class people and people of color
$100,000 indemnity payment for the black
panther - the Black Panther Party there
were about 10 more similar planks on the
platform on which I was elected in an
election which I suspect until this time
is still the one that bought involved
more more students than any other
probably in MIT s history it certainly
involved the administration in a
significant way campaigning for the
other candidates the difference between
1965 and 1969 was that in the interim
students on this campus like the ones
who set up the peace and justice Center
in fact identical to them had gone into
the dorms and talked one-to-one with
people they had held meetings with
people in which people were entreated
and helped to express what they really
felt about what was going on will come a
bit later - what in fact they really did
feel and what our response was we did
all sorts of demonstrations we painted
the walls of MIT at other schools that
might not be so relevant but in MIT tell
you one more every once in a while I'll
do a
anecdote about MIT MIT is MIT produces
technocrats Harvard produces ruling
class elite who make decisions bu
produces people who fill middle level
strata I didn't know that at first but
when I was here early on I went over and
I sat in on a few classes at bu and I
was astounded I was astounded by their
magnitude by the absolute lack of
participation of anybody in anything
having to do with education any student
by the utter dissociation of the faculty
from the students by a lot of
characteristics then I went up to
Harvard there I was blown away I was
blown away by the fact that they had
plush rugs in the classrooms that they
lived in suites that were small scale
miniature models of boardrooms that they
were literally that that that everything
about the school was structured in such
a way as to produce a certain kind of
product not a person mind you but an
elite CEO politician etc then I came
back to MIT before this I had no notion
that MIT was anything other than a
school good school I came back to MIT
and I looked around and it was quite a
contrast
I saw grey walls as far as you could see
I saw faculty who would come in and
write textbooks on the wall I saw an
utter lack a complete absence of emotion
such an absence of emotion that probably
the most important thing I did is an
organizer was exhibit emotion that's how
bad it was no lie and then I began to
understand why and and what I understood
was because it's because this place
means to produce a certain product and
the product is a very a very
well-trained a very capable a very
brilliant in many cases scientist or
engineer who will solve any
any problem so long as it's of some
interest and so long as somebody will
pay if somebody would pay MIT graduates
to create weapons to shoot down b-52s
and it was an interesting problem they'd
rushed to it but nobody will pay that
and so instead they create stabilization
programs for gila copters and smart
bombs and Merv's and all the rest and
they do it without so much as a wrinkle
of moral question because for them it's
not a moral issue it's simply a
technical scientific issue that's what
this place produces so the kind of
organizing that we did was relevant to
that we did things like painting the
walls we took all the couches what few
of them were and put them in public
places so people could sit in them and
talk to each other we went into classes
and we confronted people loudly
exhibiting anger and emotion and we
marched then we held teachings and we
had rallies and we had explanations and
information and then we had occupations
and then we had even more militant
demonstrations and in 1969 most of this
campus moved over to the Boston Common
not to throw rocks at the demonstration
but to join it so the first lesson is
that organizing can move people even
people who are subject to the kind of
socialization that this place can
generate the second lesson is that
people can be moved for the long or only
for the short term it's a hard lesson to
get to although it's on the face of it
very simple some of you who were there
will remember a May Day demonstration
held back then this was a demonstration
in which people were supposed to go to
Washington to shut down the city and in
the war the idea was to disrupt traffic
and distress disrupt the functioning of
the city the problem was that the
organizing fort not the conception the
conception of going to Washington and
disrupting that was fine the problem was
the way the organizing was done it was
an example of what I'd like to call
apocalyptic organizing people like where
any Davis Tom Hayden Jerry Rubin
it was a sidebar Randy Davis wound up
and insurance salesman Tom Hayden wound
up well Tom Hayden at one time thought
liberals were the lowest form of human
life if he would deign to call them
human and he wound up barely a liberal
and Jerry Rubin is some kind of a some
kind of a neo capitalist on Wall Street
these three folks along among some
others organized for this made a
demonstration and what they would do is
they would come to places like this and
they would speak to a large audiences
and they were very good speakers in fact
Rennie Davis was perhaps the best
speaker I've ever heard and they would
they would motivate powerfully but often
with hyperbole and often without
information and often with a promise
that borne no semblance of reality come
to Washington will shut down the city
and will end the war people went to
Washington disrupted the city but the
war went on and when they went home
having been organized without any real
fundamental understanding of the
tenacity of the war and of the basic
institutions that caused it
many of them would become disgruntled
and dismayed and lose their their
commitment other people among them Noam
Leslie Cagan who's currently the chief
organizer 25 years later of the event on
January 26th Dave Dellinger who
undoubtedly will be a speaker there and
is still doing that and many many others
notice all I'm still involved still
committed in the same way would organize
in a different way they would try to
motivate and to arouse and to confront
but they would also provide information
and analysis and an earnest perception
of what was possible and what it meant
to build a movement that success was
building a larger movement that success
was raising consciousness that you
didn't have to come home turn on the TV
and see an end of a war to feel success
to feel that what you
doing was part of a process that was
building something worthwhile you can
organize for the short term and get a
big bang or you can organize for the
long term and generally get just as
large an immediate demonstration and way
more commitment the third lesson is that
you can organize people around symbols
around reality at the at MIT one of the
things we did is we organized around the
instrumentation labs where much of that
research was going on at Princeton they
organized around a math building I
forget the name of it where research was
going on at MIT the culmination of our
work around the instrumentation labs
which included a citywide coalition that
came here for a demonstration to block
those labs which are actually a partly a
military installation and so there were
there were troops here there were
literally people on top of the buildings
with guns and all the other
paraphernalia that you'd expect the
resolution of this was that they
Jeremiah they redefined the AI labs to
be not on the campus they just call them
something else and they they they named
them after I forget the name the guy but
anyway they moved him off the campus and
and and some some of the people who had
been organized were lost because of that
because the organizing focus so strongly
not that it shouldn't have been
concerned with the AI labs but so
strongly with the AI labs and not enough
with the underlying issues and the
underlying structure that they could be
lost at Princeton the buildings in the
middle of the campus they redefined the
borders of the campus so that that plot
of ground was no longer a part of
Princeton the things still sat there it
was still functioning in the exact same
way
instrumentation sorry that's where the
helicopter stuff and the smart bombs
were done so you can organize around
that or you can organize around the
basic institutions people can be moved
narrowly or broadly we could go out and
we can organize now and there's a
tremendous desire to do it and I feel it
too about war and peace and not bother
with justice we could skip the links to
racism we could skip the links to sexism
we could skip the links to
poverty we could skip the links to
homophobia we could skip all that
because hey in two hours we may have
bombs raining from the sky it would be a
mistake it is not the way to organize a
movement it is not the way to make the
most powerful statement that can be made
and it is not the way to create a
movement that can sustain itself we're
gonna come in a bit to why I think
that's the case last lesson is that
moving people really does matter if you
look back at the history of the
opposition among elites to the war after
all if we do get out if we do if we do
decide not to start the war in Iraq or
if we go in and then we stop the war it
will be elites after all who make that
decision who put their name on that
decision so you have to look at how do
they respond what do they respond to in
making decisions about war and peace or
for that matter about any other social
issue if you look at the record of the
of the speeches of the Senators and the
Congress people from the period of the
Vietnam War and of the CEOs and lawyers
and doctors and so on who were public
enough figures to go public when they
became doves as it was called when they
decided they were against the war you
find over and over again that they give
more in variant or another the same
speech that speech doesn't talk about
the lives of the Vietnamese people it
doesn't talk about the lives of American
GIs it does not talk about resources
taken away from this society from the
United States which cannot go to
bettering situation here it doesn't
mention those things the Congress people
the senators they didn't mention any of
that when they changed sides when they
said that they were no longer against
the war they said our streets are in
turmoil
we're losing the next generation there's
the there's the possibility that all
these people who are demonstrating are
going to soon challenge the basic
institutions in addition to the war what
they said will
for me the social cost of pursuing a
policy I want to pursue the war is too
high these movements are raising costs
that are so high that I can no longer
pursue what I really want to pursue
George Bush does not give a [ __ ] about
dead American GIs he does not care and
it's important to understand that if
we're gonna understand what we have to
do to get him and the powers behind him
to react he does not care he doesn't
even conceive that there's anything that
there's any issue to care about of dead
Iraqis for dead Jordanians or dead
Palestinians that isn't even a concept
for him he does not care about huge sums
of money going into the military and not
into dealing with racism or crumbling
school systems or crumbling
infrastructure or a lack of housing in
the United States not only doesn't he
care about that I think that's a
significant part of the purpose he does
care about the possibility of social
movements challenging capital
challenging his rule challenging the
two-party system challenging the the
basic institutions of patriarchy he
cares about no business as usual he
cares about disruption he cares about
dissent if he cares about a dead GI it's
because it might provoke to sin that's
all if he cares about any of these
issues it's because it might provoke
dissent that tells us that not only does
organizing work but that the product of
organizing dissent and demonstrations
also can work they can win they can make
change they can change policies they can
change basic trends they can change the
consciousness of a nation if you look at
this country now and you look at this
country at the post start of the Vietnam
War you'll see that the movements in the
interim have had an unbelievably
powerful effect on a psyche of America
what we learn from what they respond to
is that it's necessary to have movements
that have more than one tactic a
demonstration in Washington is a
powerful thing it displays large numbers
of people who are dissenting a
demonstration in Washington which is
accompanied by a civil disobedience
demonstration is a more powerful thing
it says not only are people
demonstrating but they are then moving
on to disrupt to civilly disobey and
everybody knows that the commitment and
the involvement and the consciousness
change that's associated with that leak
means a lasting commitment and so the
threat to the interest that they hold
dear is that much greater we have to
make our dissent visible and militant we
have to have a movement which has a
place for people just moving just
beginning and a place for people whose
anger and whose consciousness and whose
awareness has gotten to the point where
they're ready to do civil disobedience
what is it about the United States that
makes it so hard to organize I'll pick
up the pace but I do want to address
this a bit it's part of it we live in a
country that has an economy that's
capitalist its profit oriented it has
private ownership it has competitive
markets it has 30 billionaire's and 31
million poor people we live in a country
that has a culture that it's racist
ethnocentric violent exclusionary we
live in a country that has kinship
arrangements that are sexist patriarchal
homophobic political arrangements that
call themselves Democratic but are
actually muddy driven and media
dominated and I thought democratic in
the sense that elites had a degree of
democracy but I'm even beginning to
wonder about that now given Bush's power
and his capability to override elite the
scent of which there is plenty these
institutions create
hierarchies among us class hierarchies
gender hierarchies race hierarchies and
they create consciousnesses that make it
hard for us to act passivity cynicism a
belief that nothing better is possible
they also create a intelligencia that's
bought off that's more interested in its
well-being financial well-being than in
the truth about media powerful police
these things make organizing have
difficult these sets of institutions
breed the international relations the
international outcomes I described they
also read read domestic problems where
the richest country in the world far and
away we have 31 million poor people
there are three million people in the
United States homeless who eat garbage
can dinners and sleep in alleys the
richest country in the world
40% of all Latino children and 50% of
all black children golf poor half of all
black children golf poor one person in
twenty in the United States suffer some
form of burglary assault rape or murder
each year there are 250 reported rapes
daily one every six minutes probably ten
times that number of unreported ribs
there's a brutal beating of a woman
every 19 seconds probably more there's
one successful suicide in the United
States every 20 minutes and ten times
that number that fail in the richest
country in the world that's the product
of organism institutional structures
that are based on class division gender
division race division and political
elitism the reason I became a
revolutionary is because I believed that
those problems were not accidents they
weren't bad policies there were natural
outgrowth of those underlying structures
one-half of 1% of all US citizens hold
one-third of all us wealth the average
CEO chairman of the corporation earns as
much as ninety three factory workers or
seventy two teachers and they earn that
not counting the interest that they earn
those thirty billionaire's
those folks are earning two million
dollars a week in interest when I came
here I was this is I was rushed to a
fraternity mit has a fraternity system
explain something about why it's hard to
organize people myself and the
fraternities were sort of a plus at
least at that time those of us who went
into them we thought they were more
social better place to live it's
arguably not true but we felt that and
we were rushed and I went to rush week
and from my perspective what I saw
during rush week was I was ushered into
the building and I got good food and
people were wonderful and nice and
friendly and I was catered to and they
attempted to try and get me to join
their various fraternities this would
last for a period of time and it's a
very active time in this tremendous
effort I joined a fraternity and then we
went through what's called what do you
call it when you get into a fraternity
and pledging and that went on for four
four months or so MIT is too
sophisticated for the normal kind of
hazing sophisticated remember this is
the place building smart bombs MIT is
too sophisticated for the normal kind of
hazing so instead what they did is they
had the freshman clean the place every
Friday night from about 8 o'clock until
about 3 o'clock in the morning now at
MIT you don't have that much time to
yourself so it's not a small thing to
work from 8 o'clock to 3 o'clock in the
morning cleaning the floors and then
cleaning them again and then cleaning
him again for 4 months at the end of
that 4 months we were inducted as
full-fledged members of fraternity and
we went to a meeting and they told us
something very interesting they told us
that during rush week they had tapped
the telephones and the fraternity where
we stayed over and they had bugged the
rooms tapped the telephones and bugged
the rooms we asked why and they said
well you had to make a difficult
decision very quickly where to live and
we researched you for
and we were calmer and older and more
mature and we were in a better position
to make that decision than you so what
we did is we tapped the phones and we
bugged the rooms so that we would hear
what you would say when you called your
parents or and at that time your I don't
know what at that time it was your
girlfriend and it was all men or any
other friend and you described what you
were interested in so if I called
somebody and said this place is really
nice but nobody plays tennis seven
o'clock the next morning tennis game for
me no lie if I said I thought I thought
that I'd have more intellectual
stimulation here I thought there'd be
more people who would be into physics
and they wanted me I forgot to mention
this was for the people who they wanted
the people the process was a two-tiered
one in the fraternity when I went into
they had a little chain people would
because you could go any to any living
group that you wanted to try and become
a part of and they literally researched
all incoming freshmen and they know who
they wanted everybody who they didn't
want they just funneled through the
building out the door and into the back
alley and once they wanted went upstairs
and they tried to get you to stay over
so they could tap your phone and bug
your room now the reason I bring this
story up is because when they told if
they had told us the day after rush week
if they had told me the day after rush
week that they tapped my phone I would
have gone berserk berserk but when they
told me after five months of hazing that
they tap my phone in other words after I
had invested only 20 Friday nights but
still 20 Friday nights and after I had
become friends and become involved and
gotten some status associated with this
fraternity when they told me in the 20
other incoming freshmen we all took it
we didn't do [ __ ] we didn't get upset we
were part of the gang
we abided by it well for some reason
that I don't know something happened in
me and and I I had a little trouble with
it but I didn't quit I just sort of
thought about it and I stay in the
fraternity for the next six months and
actually I was sort of the I was pretty
verbal and out
going and I was sort of the fair-haired
you know up-and-comer with a fraternity
and they even they charge your life they
charted that I was gonna be their
candidate for you ap four years later
irony of ironies it's the truth it's the
honest truth well at the end of the year
I went home for the summer and I started
writing to some of the freshmen with me
and I decided that I had been a fool and
and and I decided to leave and I came
back and the first political thing I did
was i sat on a defender of a car outside
a PI Alpha Epsilon Pi was the fraternity
and I told the freshmen who are coming
in rush week what was going on
well what happened what happened was
very amusing there was a brawl half the
return and he wanted to get me the other
half didn't want the embarrassment of
their having gotten me and they fought
with each other this is amusing but
what's really what's what's the point of
this story is that in subsequent weeks
the rest of my class or all but five or
six of them left that fraternity and
that group of people became the core of
what was called Rosa Luxemburg SDS and
that group of people is the group of
people who did what was done here at MIT
along with others and there was nothing
absolutely nothing to distinguish me or
any other of the others of those people
from everybody else in the freshman
class except the trauma and the the
mindset change that was associated in
this case not with understanding
imperialism but with understanding a
form of local feudalism in this
fraternity and then the opening of
ourselves that it led to to
understanding something about the world
and the radicalization that ensued
notice that it only took 20 Friday
nights to hold us off for six months
plus the socialization of the gray walls
and the promise of being a big physicist
and all the rest of that everybody in
the United States has some forces
working on them that make it very hard
to move to the left there's the
socialization
there's ignorant among many there's
there's literal ignorance literal belief
and the lies as the pressures of
maintaining your family or trying to get
yourself in there and there's the
awareness that I think really exists
deep down in most people that opposition
has an implication that going to the
demonstrations once leads to going twice
and that going twice leads to going five
times and everybody knows that the first
step is the big step the first time you
go do C D is the big time because you
might just get sucked in it might become
your life instead of being the physicist
you might well whatever and to build a
movement that's going to attract people
over that hurdle means building a
movement that is not so abrasive that
it's less fun and less pleasant and less
empowering to be in than a classroom at
MIT it means building a movement that's
not so sexist that women literally can't
stand it it means building a movement
that is not so dominated by white
culture that black people and Latino
people find it just as a [ __ ] --nt as a
society outside it means building a
movement that's not so hierarchical then
that it replicates the Congress and it
means
and it means and this I think although
it's the least talked about thing is
probably the hardest thing it means
building a movement in which a few
intellectuals don't dominate everybody
else in which we don't replicate class
structure not just race and gender and
sexual and the other structures outside
but also class structure it means
creating a movement that will welcome
people and that will empower people of
all backgrounds and that will respect
the fact that by and large they know a
whole lot more about what's wrong with
the country and about what should be
done to the country then the people who
have the training to be eloquent and to
dominate decision-making and to dominate
discussions and we have to be attuned to
that I think we should
I think we should stop but I do want to
make one plea I heard this evening I
don't have the details but I heard this
evening that tomorrow there will be
civil disobedience at the federal
building there will also be some actions
that will be hard for people to to move
into that will be by smaller groups I
guess in in in other places and I can't
identify them because I don't know the
details but there will be civil
disobedience at the federal building I'm
quite sure there will also be marches
and rallies and I suspect they'll also
be teachings do whatever it is that's
comfortable for you to do but do
something because because the people who
are for the war have an excuse not to do
something but I bet everybody here is
against the war and I bet everybody here
is against all of the implications of
the war and to be against the war and to
be against all of the implications of
the war and to do nothing it's hypocrisy
and you have to think about that and
it's very important for people to act in
the way that you want to in the manner
that you want to with others who you
choose but to do it and if we do I think
we can have a serious impact
[Applause]
okay just two announcements more
information about the civil disobedience
that Michael Albert spoke about it's
says put the brakes on war let's not go
to war for our gasoline and the plan is
to block traffic during rush hour on
Boston's major arteries sending a clear
message to Washington and the world that
we will not allow business to proceed as
usual while people are dying for our
gasoline and they plan to block the JFK
Federal Building and it's gathering at
the SEIU Local 285 which is the seventh
floor 145 Trent Street across from the
common at 7:00 p.m. for those who are
interested at 7:00 p.m. at the JFK
[Music]
somebody 7:00 a.m. 7:00 a.m. tomorrow
boy okay okay sorry about that somebody
give me we're gonna okay and there's
just one correction that needs to be
made on that and that's that the March
for the day after the either the
shooting or the bombing begins that's
supposed to take place at toss does not
begin at 1:45 p.m. as indicated on the
sheet but rather at 12:30 p.m. okay and
now we can begin with question and
answers
would people like to race okay
well I think a credible sane position is
the one that most of the world is taking
namely rely on sanctions and pursue the
diplomatic track I don't think that
sanctions should involve things like
food
I definitely sorry there's nothing
especially right on this position of the
National Council of Churches for example
you know we're not out on left field and
it's the position of most of the world
the sanctions in this case will cut off
Iraqi oil exports which is their total
export trade and sooner or later they
will and probably sooner it will have
the effect of opening up a diplomatic
track in fact it may have had that
effect last August and we know what the
contours of a diplomatic settlement are
I mentioned a couple of examples they're
perfectly reasonable they've even been
proposed by Iraq according to US
officials so there's a viable course I
don't understand what the big problem is
now a viable course is to say okay let's
consider the proposal of January 2nd
then let's see if it's going to work
that's a reasonable proposal it's
perfectly reasonable to have a mattock
settlement of the Arab Israel
conflict the United States has been
blocking it for twenty years and we
should oppose that we should have such a
settlement it's perfectly reasonable to
have a diplomatic settlement of the very
serious problem of weapons of mass
destruction in the region fine let's
stop opposing that apparently if we stop
opposing those two things we can arrange
for Iraqi withdrawal from quoits oh I
don't understand what the problem is
problem in fact I do understand what the
problem is the problem is the United
States won't accept those outcomes but
from our point of view you know having a
credible answer I don't think that's
very hard in fact most of the world has
that answer well the facts are pretty
clear
Iraq released transcripts of meetings
and they were basically agreed to be
authentic by the United States these
were meetings right on the eve of the
invasion between April Glaspie who was
the US ambassador and is in fact one of
the big State Department experts on Iraq
she was the US ambassador to Iraq with
she had meetings with Saddam Hussein I
there was forget a day or two before the
invasion and there was also testimony
but from from the State Department here
public testimony all of which the the
basic tenor of it was that the United
States recognized that Iraq had claims
against quate and it had no particular
no particular position on the border
issues now there's basically the two
border issues that I mentioned one has
to do with access to the Gulf and that
involves you know these two islands on
inhabited islands the other has to do
with this one contested oil field and
the u.s. position was we have no
position on those things now Saddam
because we just it's very hard the
second to figure out what's going on in
Saddam Hussein's head but a fair
speculation is he assumed that that was
a green light that's possible
however there's a further speculation
here which is not totally without
credibility I must say but I don't
believe it and that is that the United
States tried to draw him in which does
have some advantages for the US there's
no doubt about it
I mean from you know from the point of
view of this this mad strategic logic
that I was talking about there's some
point to having at least maybe a war or
at least the threat of war it gives the
u.s. bases in the region you know it
establishes the efficacy if force gives
a shot to the domestic Pentagon system
which was in some trouble and so on so
yeah however I just think it's extremely
unlikely that the attempt was to draw
him in it's much too dangerous I mean
unless people are really crazy they
wouldn't have done that it's not saying
it's impossible
and you know there's it's not the
argument for it is not zero but I don't
believe it myself I think what happened
is Saddam Hussein probably interpreted
it as authorization as saying well the
United States doesn't care so I'll move
in and then when the u.s. perceived that
this guy is not just a loyal puppet but
rather an independent nationalist then
all of a sudden he's got to go
notice that the invasion of Kuwait
didn't really add very much to his
crimes didn't add a lot and it didn't
bring him up to the level of plenty of
people we support like General Suharto
and Indonesia for example but it did
show that he was an independent
nationalist and that's the ultimate
crime if you're an independent
nationalist you can be you know a
conservative parliamentary Democrat you
can be a right-wing military figure you
can be a left-wing organizer than matter
what you are you got to be knocked off
because that's the one thing the US will
not tolerate Hussein's like Noriega
Noriega we ostensibly removed because we
were concerned about his interaction and
his involvement in international drugs
then we proceeded to install bankers
money launderers for the drug cartel as
the government of Panama putting the lie
to the motivation the real motivation
was again
admittedly a thug admittedly a
terian you know person but a nationalist
but I want to relay although I agree
with with Noam I want to relay a
conversation that I had in October I had
a conversation with a fella named john
stockwell who some of you may know who
he is
he he's a yeah he he's an ex-cia agent
who is now on our side and has done a
great deal of work for peace and for
justice and i asked him what he thought
about what was going on and it was much
before now it was back in early November
and he he took me by surprise he said in
the absence of sufficient domestic
dissent there will be war and the reason
there will be war he said I have to
explain that to you I have to tell you
how we think about it in the CIA and I
don't think this is the best way to
think about it but he did tell me how
they teach you to think about these
things in the CIA and they said you
can't really look at the immediate
context for your full understanding
because it's too volatile and it's too
fraught with possible confusion you have
to look at the history of the country
and ask does it periodically go to war
or not in this case both sides yes if it
does periodically go to war what are the
indices which tend to be exhibited in
the country when it goes to war and you
look at those indices he says he told me
and he said if you look at the indices
for the United States you find war you
find the economy decaying you find the
the possibility of the public to the
policies of the government being
undermined the peace dividend and you
find the possibility of a large-scale
war being a way to alleviate that
problem as well as to pursue the course
of becoming the world's mercenary state
and he felt and I relay it for what it's
worth I don't I don't know what to make
of it he felt after all he was in there
that if we weren't in this position with
Hussein right now we would be in this
position with Cuba that literally
Hussein was a gift not an arrangement
not a not a trap but a gift that
Hussein's activities provided exactly
what they wanted and it
sort of go a long ways to explain our
absolute unwillingness to get out of
this and anything short of what we're
facing just take a couple more questions
and then we will have a question and
answer that will take place at the
student center where no man Michael
Albert have both promised to spend a few
more minutes at this Peace Center
answering questions so
well you know we have experience on that
back in the 60s yeah plenty of
experience the the there I mean every
time there has been dissent there has
been repression some of it got exposed
like for example during the nineteen
sixties the I don't know how many of you
felt know about the COINTELPRO program
that was big FBI program which went
through holes actually it started in the
30s but it really picked up under
Kennedy and it targeted first the
Communist Party then the Puerto Rican
nationalists movement then the the black
movements all of them the civil rights
movement all the peace movements the
entire New Left the American Indian
Movement everybody and that reached to
the level of actual political
assassination you know like the worst
case was the Gestapo style assassination
of a black panther organizer probably
drugged in bed by the Chicago Police
with an FBI cover it also taught in I
mean it also did things that it or
instigated race riots and violence in
the ghettos and took credit for killings
the only a lot of this documentation
came out on you know court cases and
things like that you know I said did
things that were like a joke so like I
mean I was one of the targets of it at
MIT I mean this is just a joke but just
to give you the kinds of things they do
they give you some insight into the FBI
they had they were forced under court
order to release to release documents
and here's what's going to go on at MIT
they they were forced under court order
to release the art documents for people
who had targeted under COINTELPRO and
two of the people who were targeted were
teaching assistants in a course that
Louie Kemp and I thought that Mike was
in a couple of times and other people
back in the sixties and these guys the
two people who were teaching assistants
were guys in the draft resistance
movement and other things we sort of
brought people in you know who
could do good things and could use the
job and that sort of thing and the here
the seek there sequence of FBI documents
got released under court orders starts
like this first one from the Boston
office to J Edgar Hoover says we've
discovered that these two guys are
teaching assistants at MIT that would be
a good we think that'd be a good our
source it says our source within MIT and
then something's blacked out and we'll
figure out who it was our source within
MIT tells us that these two guys are
teaching assistants this be good target
for this information operation can we
have authors to get them kicked out can
we have authorization for it and then
I'll thing comes back from dead your
Hoover saying yeah it sounds like a good
idea go ahead now goes up and back for a
while and finally at the end the last
one from the Boston office says our
source within MIT tells us that all this
stuff has worked and these two guys are
not going to be hired next year so we
succeeded the only problem with that
story is it was a Codel fake these two
guys were going off to their next piece
of work they never had the slightest
intention of coming back to spend
another term at MIT and the whole thing
had been cooked up in an FBI office and
certainly that's one of the kinds of
things that goes on in FBI offices and
an agent has a caseload and it's a lot
easier not to go after guys in the Mafia
you know cuz like they shoot back but if
you fiddle around with people like us
we're not gonna shoot back you know even
if they did it and that kind of stuff
will go on so everything from probably
faked and invented harassment to really
serious things like organizing political
assassinations and ghetto riots that's
the kind of thing that will go on that's
been going on all through American
history at a very rough history of
repression of dissonance
you know repression is is certainly a
real phenomenon but it's not it's not as
effective as it's often led on to be
unless we let it be there's two things
that I'd like to suggest that are
critical to having the kind of
activities that they engage in the
infinitely less effective than they
otherwise might be the first is you have
to have support if you have substantial
support really massive support it's very
hard to repress an instance of that here
at MIT was MIT thought it was very
clever they got an injunction in which
they listed about 10 of us - that we
weren't allowed on the campus and we
were to be arrested on site on the day
of a demonstration so the 10 of us and
many thousands of other people came to
MIT and we stood on the on the steps and
ripped it up and with many thousands of
people there and with many more
thousands who would have supported us it
was very difficult to do anything about
it that's one answer to repression the
second side of repression is
infiltration and the kind of thing that
was done to the Panthers and to many
other groups and while that activity is
effective and that activity is deadly
and it's impossible to stop it entirely
it is possible to do better than we did
then what we did then often was to
construct a movement in which a
policeman was at home in which a
policeman was not immediately obvious if
you have a movement which is really
humane and which is really democratic
and in which macho behavior stands out
like a sore thumb police agents have a
very hard time infiltrating we have
never found one we have never
encountered one who can operate in that
kind of context in an effective fashion
and that's not a small thing that can
save lives in addition to building a
movement that it's worth being a part of
wait a minute yeah
three
oh there's logic behind it you could
argue about whether we just put purely
cynical you know forgetting anything
about morality we even know some of the
background for it
in 1948 oh the question was what's the
logic behind the US support of Israel
and notice it's pretty strong support
we're supporting them to the extent of
rejecting a political settlement
blocking a political settlement using it
as a base to go to war and so on
refusing to arrange for reduction of you
know we claim to be concerned about
Iraqi weapons of mass destruction but
not at the cost of getting Israel to
eliminate its nuclear weapons you know
not that cost so the supply and the
support is official support is around
three billion a year actually comes to
more than that and all of that is
expensive and then there's all these
Arab countries around with oil like the
Gulf oil Principality so what's the
logic well there's a real logic and let
me just run through it quick quickly for
uh starting in 1948 when Israel was
founded right after Israel began the at
that point they wouldn't clear what to
do but Israel won some pretty big
military victories very fast in fact
even before the state was established it
already expanded quite considerably in
the Civil War and the Joint Chiefs of
Staff concluded right then that Israeli
power would be a good base for the
United States in the region they said
after turkey Israel is the major
military power in the region and it can
it can be an outpost of us strength
especially with Britain and trouble our
lieutenant was in trouble in the region
and this would be a base for using force
ultimately have to use force to control
people that continued so in 1958 the
National Security Council had a
memorandum in which they recommend they
concluded that opposition they said a
logical corollary to our opposition to
radical Arab nationalism that means
independence a logical corollary to our
opposition to independent nationalism
would be support for Israel as the one
reliable Pro you pro-western state in
the region and it goes on like that in
the 1960s
the Defense Intelligence Agency we know
in fact the whole intelligence system
regarded Israel as a barrier against
Nasser's pressure on the Gulf oil
producers and in fact by that time an
alliance was being set up which was kind
of formalized under the Nixon doctrine
around 1970 an alliance between Israel
Iran under the Shah and Saudi Arabia you
know in which Iran and Israel were the
tough guys who kept anybody under
control and made sure that the ruling
family of Saudi Arabia would stay rich
and powerful and not be threatened and
worked for us now it's not the smart
guys and people the more intelligent
analysts in the United States were
entirely aware of this so for example
Senator Henry Jackson who at that time
was the Senate's leading specialist and
energy in Middle East and so on and I
was a big hawk and very pro-israel he
spilled the whole story publicly and
correct correctly he said that he said
just what I said more or less I mean he
put a little different words but
basically he said that Israel and Iran
under the Shah are reliable powerful
states which can protect the Gulf oil
producers from disruption by radical
elements now Saudi Arabia is not a
country that has documents that you can
find you know so we'll never have a
document every record from Saudi Arabia
but when the US records come out for
that period and unless they're destroyed
or censored I said I predict what we're
going to find what we're going to find
there's an actual alliance between Saudi
Arabia Israel and the Shah from the
Saudi Arabian daily point of view
Israel's fine now they may yell about it
and this and that but they're happy they
want to have a again a what's called a
cop but you have to be pretty cynical
about the police to use this phrase
rent-a-cop they want a thug around you
know a rent-a-thug around who's going to
suppress radical tendencies will be a
base for power and that goes right on to
the president meanwhile by the 1970s
Israel had begun to take on other roles
it was becoming a mercenary State it was
used by the u.s. in the 60s under a big
CIA subsidy dependent
black Africa it was used in Asia was
used in Latin America it's and it's
useful for a big terrorist country like
the United States it's useful to have a
mercenary state around see other
countries higher individual terrorists
but we don't we use mercenary States
terrorist states we're big shots you
know and a little bit of this came out
in the iran-contra hearings and if
you'll notice there was an alliance
between Israel and Saudi Arabia in fact
what actually happened this is part of
the story suppressed and the iran-contra
hearings but it's all in the public
record I was writing about in the early
80s immediately after the fall of the
Shah immediately no hostages nothing
about hostages years before there were
hostages immediately after the fall of
the Shah the United States started
sending arms to Iran via Israel page
whereby Saudi Arabia and the Israeli
high Israeli officials who were involved
in it were completely open and public
same guys who showed up later in the
iran-contra hearings they talked said
exactly what was going on what was going
on was the United States was doing the
standard thing that you do when you're
trying to overthrow a government support
its military you want to overthrow a
government you support it send arms to
its military that's the way you get
you'd make contacts with elements in the
military whoever throw the government
for you that's the way we overthrew the
government of Indonesia of Chile case
after case and they were just running
the same game and even in in the highly
suppressed story of the damage control
operation that was called the
iran-contra hearings you look you can
still see it there was an Iran Israel
Saudi Arabia connection and that's that
old connection now you know those are
reasons there's also intelligence
interactions Israel can do things for
the United States Israel tests advanced
weapons in live battlefield conditions
against defenseless targets that's
useful that's part of what went on and
things like the Lebanon War there's
weapons common weapons development you
know there's all kinds of things so from
some points of you know the Israeli
Lobby they Jewish lobby these you know
they pro-israeli Lobby here they claim
that Israel is really a bargain and
they've got an argument you know if
these are the things you want done in
the world
that's an argument in fact I'll just
finally conclude at the same time 1948
when the Joint Chiefs were noticing that
Israel's the dominant military one of
the dominant military forces in the
region the Israeli State Archives which
have since been public partially
released they also commented on what was
going on and they described the
Palestinians as what they said human
dust and human waste who will just
become part of the debris of the Arab
world as they scatter and that was the
position of the u.s. - now if you got a
choice between two groups one of them a
tough militarized advanced Western state
and the other people who can just become
more of the human dust that floats
around the world you know which one
people in power are going to support and
that's still their view that's been
their view from 1948 to today and that
explains why they're doing what they do
I know there are a lot of questions and
what we've promised to do is have an
extended question-and-answer session
that will now take place in the Student
Center and we also invite everyone else
to participate in other activities that
will be going on there
you